[Music]
hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic guy
remember it so you don't have to when I
first reviewed alien versus Predator I
said the whole film was kinda like a
battle between your jock side and your
intellectual side well thankfully with
the sequel you don't have to worry about
that because everybody loses
[Music]
remember your thoughts on the first
alien vs. predator everyone agrees its
sequel sucks major dick shaped alien
head even with an actual R rating this
time people mostly came out of the
theater still saying the same thing I
say we take off and nuke the entire site
from orbit it missed with fans and
missed with critics so what is it about
this film that pissed everyone off so
much well giving directors who worked
out Nickelback video sure wasn't a great
start and it also led to a quick end
with the film costing close to 130
million to make and turning in only 40
million dollars in ticket sales so let's
see how it became game over' lamb for
this franchise this is alien vs.
predator Requiem I'd be lying if I said
there wasn't a part of me that loved
mixing both the Alien and Predator style
credits even the intro isn't bad when
the alien from the last film first out
of the same predator causing their ship
to crash land back on earth be very very
quiet
I'm hunting clever girls it looks like a
couple of facehuggers attack both the
hunter and the kid not a bad start I
dare even say it's kind of badass but
the film gets pretty standard and lame
quick when it cuts to a nearby suburban
town where the only reason you make a
square out is just a manager made you
wear a hat with never a drop make the
run where you're fired and wear the hats
that already feels like an alien vs.
predator movie Pizza hats classic it
looks like our main character Ricky
didn't want to make the delivery because
a girl he likes named Jesse happens to
live there and happens to have a jackass
boyfriend with some jackass other
friends
yeah Halloween in October yeah people
with jobs make me sick so I'm gonna flex
my pecs until they explode what the hell
am i doing she pays for the pizza
but looks like seizure pax isn't done
yet find them in 30 minutes or less
asshole is it really worth going bad and
same for this insult as now I know who
ordered the sausage lovers it's kind of
like an overreaction maybe these guys
are like you if our friend sexual
discoveries to his own pacing you guys
talking about come on man we know you're
so deep in the closet you're naming the
coat hangers
I'm not gay let's go watch some cooking
show okay that sounds great
I look Jesse just standing there like
let's go well he said let's go I'm
powerless to thwart his logic alien
versus Predator folks were sorry the
sheriff shows up to check out the crash
ship where it has even by this film
standards a pretty shitty fake out well
yeah what else do you think we would see
there the alien driving a car do you
have any Grey Poupon there's literally
grey kindly smear it on yourself and
await my instructions we next cut to a
soldier returning home from the army yes
her kid is so happy she's home after so
long she immediately asked what she got
for her these for me you don't like them
kidding me they're so cool oh and I
guess I miss you after being away for so
long can this play arena of Valor
meanwhile one of the Predators lands on
earth to locate the ship and very slowly
figures out what happened
you think this be boring and
uninteresting but you're wrong it's
really boring and uninteresting
okay audience give me a bit I didn't see
the same part of the movie you did so I
got to figure this out let's see it's
called alien versus Predator so that
would mean the facehuggers are having a
picnic upstairs no no I would be rated R
then unless they're using some very
harsh language please cut away from me
here we go I'm in a house well things
are gonna get interesting now oh never
mind it wasn't me it was just a bad fake
out
in fact why are you still hearing me
then I want dad to read it okay miss kid
is so weird and her affection to her
mother that her father has to come in
and remind her what her motivation is
you remember all this time she told me
how much you missed mommy it's okay to
tell mommy that unless she gets angry at
daddy for playing too much Xbox in which
case you can be a little cold
Ricky's brother Dallas Howard I too will
not be able to separate that returns
home from prison and helps Ricky get his
keys in the sewer yeah you're totally
gonna find it down there guys
you know when keys get lost they sniff
you out and find their way home no I'm
just getting their keys what the hell
are you guys doing wrong the correct
answer is what the hell is a couch doing
in the cellar it's this hobo snick
oh no it's something this movie is too
goddamn dark meanwhile a search party is
looking for the hunter and his son while
the predator hunts to one of the most
annoying parts of the movie is every
time it cuts to his vision it makes this
a matches ass sound effect I don't
remember doing that all the time in the
other movies it sounds like the
testicles on simon belmont slipped
dropped and he won't stop showing it off
are you sure this is necessary meanwhile
Ricky's brother continues to look for
work how's the job hunt going
Breaking and Entering a special skill
suggestions there's an opening for
ant-man down the street I want you to
break into a place and steal some stuff
she comes across one of his men that
predator killed and Dallas is still
looking for work he could try Undertaker
I mean if they took in Steve Bannon here
it'll take anyone what are you gonna do
I figure well I'll continue being a gene
splicer Brian Cox and Philip Seymour
Hoffman not that the alien vs. predator
Requiem audience knows who they are
hey Jessie approaches Rick and tells him
that she fired her boyfriend no really
that's the terminology she uses and it's
ex-boyfriend actually he's been fired
what can I say he didn't raise profits
in my southern regions so the predator
finally finds the alien and seeing how
this has said in suburbia we're really
gonna change things up by having them
fight in a dark wet enclosed area whoa
slow down there's only so much ground
breaking we can do in this movie in that
I want you to break the ground so you
can go to the surface and actually be a
better movie that's eventually what they
end up doing and maybe the more I think
about it I don't want to see them in the
everyday world you can kinda look goofy
like when the waitress sees our boss
being attacked something alien coming
through swinging doors is hilarious what
she gets attacked by the predator alien
hybrid we have yet another confusing
fake-out
I don't think you know how fake outz
work you can't just put creepy music
over everything and then suddenly expect
that to start off scary the scene
doesn't even go anywhere it was
literally just cut in there to be a
quote gotcha moment even though there
was nothing to gotcha with just random
creepy music if that was the case I
could just put creepy music over what
I'm saying and it suddenly be scary
I mean think about
and when she came to she was a poodle
but you all know that
[Applause]
you
[Music]
hi guys I'm chaplain Doug's new kitty
have you heard about this Mouse on a
string god I love this Mouse on a string
until I get bored by it a little bored
by the mouse on the street now I'm back
to it Mouse's on strings are great and
did you know that you can see Doug and
the rest of the gang at Grand Rapids
comic-con
it's November 9th to the 11th it'll be
my owner Doug what a great guy
his brother Rob what a great guy Malcolm
ray great guy
Tamra chambers great guy and Jim Jay
Roth coincidentally also a great guy
there's a lot of other great guests
there so we hope you check them out me
I'm gonna go ruined Doug's couch what a
great couch oh that wasn't supposed to
happen
isn't that great I'm just gonna snip
this for a while I love sniffing this
for a while up that one fell too if I'm
just gonna keep sniffing this one for a
while I'm a really weird cat so go to
this site to figure out how you can get
tickets to Grand Rapids Comic Con in
Michigan and smelt scratching posts on
couches you don't know what you're
missing this is great
you
so the chef tells Dallas not only about
the dead copy found peel like a banana
but how he also can't find the hunter
and the kid maybe if you follow that
loud crashing spaceship that a ton of
people must have noticed including the
hunter and kid and with NASA caveum
asleep when this thing crashed how did
nobody notice this thing listen no no no
the house come on all right in the back
boy he sure it's trusting to a guy who
is an ex-con
I dare even say him being an ex-con has
absolutely no impact on the story
whatsoever so it kind of makes
everything even more puzzling come on
all right in the bag no Kate but try and
steal my keys again and I you know I'll
do nothing our monsters go from the dark
and and close sewer to the dark and
enclosed industrial site and as long as
they're smoking pipes they can jerk off
to their good some began to think these
predators couldn't find an alien if it
was right under them floor did by my
lazy next refusal to look down meanwhile
Ricky go swimming with his new date you
tell me are you looking at me the clock
is she asking him or the audience cuz
we're looking at the clock but get this
the boyfriend she foyer locates them at
the pool and brings apparently the only
two friends this kid has dammit I knew I
should have posted I was going here on
Facebook and I also show up I'm friend
of my ex dum-dum the predator knocks off
the power though as one of the aliens
enters the pool don't do that you'll
multiply all imeem that he'll come back
and draws revenge I mean out what
generic series a my own again
tell everyone I got the third base with
your girlfriend back of the soldiers
house we'll get maybe the only funny
scene when the kid says she saw a
monster outside see no monster that's
just funny daughter therapy sex is for
decades meanwhile back at the pool Ricky
has to report on what happened fuck he's
dead what wasn't it was an in-app read
it was Requiem don't worry me and this
ex-con will set things right
why is he with him no yeah so we can
tell the officer not to text and drive
while almost running somebody over real
from the police and sleepwalkers I
suggest we not report this to any cops
refused to call for backup tackle these
monsters with a bunch of teenagers and
give weapons to an ex-con yes that's
really what happened I don't think the
police station is such a hot idea
we need guts where the guns run I can't
believe I'm letting you do this this
plan is stupid that was the only
sensible part to the credit even the
National Guard seems too dumb to take
these things out oh boy oh what a happy
coincidence the soldier and her daughter
just happened to hide on the exact same
location that each time when the Alien
and Predator have to fight in their
store
well wait yes stop looking at each other
and actually do something
I'm strain that's really it we have a
whole storm crazy shit that gonna
utilize and all we got was a window
crashing who directed this Gareth
Edwards that's happening the alien sneak
into a hospital or as they call it and
all-you-can-eat buffet yeah I'm sure
alien vs. predator 2 is gonna show mass
baby slaughter this is the love the most
weak cred to do that knowing how bad
this series get the probably just
setting up a warped version of this man
to their sick disturb credit though the
alien predator hybrid seems to find a
pregnant woman and sci-fi stash it out
of her
maybe it isn't too far from this they
call the National Guard who tell them
there's an airlift in the middle of town
thank God the soldier just happened to
be trained in driving tanks welcome but
she smells a big dirty rat I think the
colonel was lying that's crazy the
government doesn't lie to people that
line is so sad the movie didn't even
need to give a punchline for it they
think you're the only other spot that
would have an airlift would be at a
yummy Hospital so the crew splits half
going to the town and the other half
going to the hospital okay that way we
can both died what a dumb line whatever
happens inside the only person that
can't get hurt is Kelly alright we all
protect Kelly what is this the Titanic
screw the women and children first ship
mass it's the Titanic screw the woman
it's on the first ship men I didn't
sound like that today look asshole
unless you can fly the helicopter shut
the fuck up well maybe if you opened
with that how do you know she can do
that anyway do they really train the
same people to operate tanks and
helicopters would it make more sense to
have a specialist for both wonder if I
could play the accordion too they go
inside I had to move for an Alien and
Predator film I'm kind of impressed how
high the body count of innocent people
in this hospital is God why don't you
just kill off the pretty girlfriend
while you're at it
that just came out of nowhere
those babies are dead aren't they
you are that goddamn crazy in the last
10 minutes why don't we wait an hour 20
for this even then most of the climax is
just watching them run away to get to
the helicopter oh god don't say it get
to the chopper you're dead to me movie
as dead as those babies you've probably
killed don't people bring their dates to
this so it's finally predator vs.
predator alien you know in the
background even when you do see it it's
so shaky and unappealing Lee green it's
like it was directed by David Fincher in
a blender
I'll just make out already you know
that's what we're all here to see but at
least the airlift is arrived for those
people that went into town ha the
helicopter of course outruns the
explosion as they come across other
military hiding in the forest
keep down your weapons and your adorable
toy gun - you bastards kill the entire
town just following orders commentary I
guess kind of came out of nowhere but oh
well the music says to be happy so we
can rap on a funny line I told you not
to crash so many people the government
murdered but I told you not to crash but
it's not over yet oh this be for another
sequel won't lead to shit I'm just
saying there's another minute left the
world isn't ready for this technology
but this isn't for our world is it miss
you Tony this movie's so bad and much
rather see a film based on the directors
credit the brothers drow sounds like an
amazing title for anything why can we
get a brother strauss movie not directed
by the brothers droughts i'll tell you
why we never got one because I came to
get a basic concept like this down there
is no home alien vs. predator it should
be so easy and yet for some reason it's
so hard
Requiem in all fairness is not a
god-awful movie it's just boring
uninspired and not particularly good to
look at I've seen much worse sequels and
I do have to give credit to the few
times that went really extreme but if
you don't care about the people or the
situations and those extreme seems they
lose their magnitude it just feels like
an uneventful movie forgettable and
meaningless I've seen a lot worse but I
definitely seen a lot better meaning
this will probably be forgotten as
quickly as what's-his-name who's our
face and something grizz's something or
other this is an easy one to skip so
come on Hollywood give me a new kind of
monster it's something different it's
something totally unique I have never
seen before and I can't even believe
they made a movie on
they couldn't have made a movie out of
it
[Music]
[Applause]
everybody so I got a kiddy his name is
Chaplin and he's super nice and social
and cute he's a little tired this
morning so he's not doing much but I
guess that's part of being a cat
well his game too is that I because we
were getting used to having a cat I've
never had a pet before uh we didn't get
a chance to do a charity shout out this
week so I'm just gonna do where we got
him which is one we've done before it's
called save a pet it's a wonderful place
we did of what you can do video on it as
well so if you want volunteer there you
definitely can he is a super-sweet cat
there's a lot of other sweet cats and
dogs there if you want to adopt one if
you want to give money donate or Ethan
just up there we go now you moving a bit
so if you want to donate a time or money
or anything you have they accept a lot
of things over there I definitely check
it out it's a wonderful site a wonderful
place with wonderful animals so
definitely go and click on the link
you